she tweets I have yet to hear a real
explanation from any official hesitating
to condemn the killing of Jordan Neely
about what makes condemning this
violence so complicated it's not
complicated there's nothing that here's
I'll tell you this AOC make it easy for
you I condemn Jordan Neely's violence I
condemn your soft on crime policies that
resulted in 25 people last year being
shoved in front of trains with two of
them dying I condemn you and your
actions and I commend the man the men
who's tried stopping this violent man
and I am sad that Jordan nearly lost his
life was that so difficult
I hand it to you panel
I mean this is also something we're
seeing a lot in my city of Vancouver
first of all I think public transport is
very quickly becoming a human rights
violation we just had an Isis stabbing
where a teenager had his throat slit on
the subway another gentleman killed I
probably a lot of you probably saw the
Starbucks stabbing in Vancouver